so today we're going to have a
presentation about big data and data
science we were fortunate enough some of
us have heard this presentation before
by Lisa Federer at the NIH library and
she's going to talk about what is Big
Data and give us an introduction to data
science techniques that can be used to
analyze it and she'll also talk about
how data science can help researchers
find meaning in data and discuss some of
the common techniques and tools used in
a variety of research areas
it's a term we're hearing a lot about
especially here at the u.s. Library of
Medicine and we thought others may want
to hear this it was very informative and
Lisa I'm going to turn this over to you
and we're unmuting your phone I guess
and I think we've turned the screen over
to you
great so can you hear me and see my
screen yes great okay so thank you so
much for having me and really pleased to
be able to get to share some this info
with all of you today so as Elizabeth
said this is going to be sort of an
introduction to data science it's a very
broad topic that we'll just cover some
of the highlights of in this session so
I want to talk a little bit first about
the concept of big data and what we're
talking about when we refer to big data
and we'll talk a little bit about data
science and how that's different from
some of the other scientific techniques
that you might be familiar with we'll
talk a little bit about sort of the
processes and methods that are used in
data science and then look at some of
the things that we are possibly going to
see ahead in the future with some of the
developments in data science and then
I'll really briefly sort of tie this
back into libraries and talk about some
of the services that we're providing at
the NIH library and some opportunities
for libraries in this sort of area so to
start out Big Data what exactly is it
it is a buzzword that we hear quite a
lot in a lot of different areas
including scientific research but a lot
of times people are using this term with
really knowing what the definition of
big data is how big does data have to be
to be big data
you know what medium do you know what
small data what what makes big data
different and so I think it's really
important to sort of understand that
before we can talk about what we're
doing with this data there's a lot of
different definitions for big data but
the one that I think is really useful
comes from I believe it originally came
from IBM and they define big data in
terms of the four V's so the first V is
volume how much of it there is so that
sort of gets back to this idea of Big
Data being data that there's a lot of
how do we define what sort of volume
makes data big data one of the ways of
thinking about that and defining that is
that when a data set becomes large
enough that we can no longer use
traditional computational tools on it
that is then Big Data so if you've ever
had the experience for example of trying
to open a very large spreadsheet in
Excel you may know that Excel can't
really handle more than a million lines
of data and when you start to get a very
large data set that it approaches that
number it gets really slow so it works
so well so we've sort of run into the
problem there that this tool that we're
trying to use is not scalable to the
volume of data that we're trying to deal
with so there are a lot of new sorts of
computational resources and techniques
that people are looking into you to
allow us to work more effectively with
these large data sets that's a very
active area of research to sort of
develop some of the tools that we would
need to work with very large volumes of
data the size of the data though is not
the only thing that distinguishes Big
Data another thing that makes Big Data a
little different to work with is the
variety of the different types of data
that we're working with so I think a
really good example of this comes from
clinical medicine so if I'm running a
clinical trial I have a lot of different
patients and for each patient I probably
have a lot of different types of
information I might have you know some
vital signs that I
from them I might have liked the history
you know of who has been ill in their
family probably written out in some sort
of narrative text I would probably have
something like maybe some scans some
MRIs and CT images I may have you know
video or audio so there's all these
different types of data that we need
from you know different formats
different kinds of media that all come
together to give us information about an
individual or scientific concept and
figuring out the ways to incorporate
those many different types of data can
be really challenging as well
the third V is velocity and this has to
do with essentially how quickly data are
able to be generated or gathered so one
of the things that is pretty cool about
the technology that we have today is
that we're able to gather data at a
really rapid rate more quickly than we
ever have been able to do in the past
and often we're able to gather that data
more quickly than we're able to analyze
it a good example of this is if you're
sort of looking at the physics realm
there's the Large Hadron Collider in I
believe Switzerland and the experiments
that they do take just a couple of
seconds to run but it generates so much
data in just those few seconds that it's
like months worth of data for teams all
around the world to work with so you
know with that technology comes you know
a lot of data and we're not quite at the
point yet where we're able to deal with
it in real time in terms of the analysis
so this is one of the challenges that
we're working with as well and then the
final of the four V's is veracity and
this sort of deals with the idea that
when we're working with very large
datasets typically most people are not
generating big data on their own they're
taking data from a repository or they're
working with some sort of a
collaborative like I mentioned the Large
Hadron Collider so it's not you know
when you would go into your lab back in
the traditional days do an experiment
and gather some data
and you sort of know where that data
came from you know how good of quality
it is because you collected it in these
sorts of situations we're working with
these more sort of big datasets that
maybe came from lots of different
sources or a source that we're not
familiar with we don't necessarily know
what the quality of the data is and we
don't necessarily know how accurate
maybe the metadata might be that goes
along with that data
so another you know challenge that we
really need to think about when we're
we're talking about Big Data is what can
we do in terms of documenting data and
documenting workflows that lead to that
data to make sure that we have good high
quality data that we're able to use on
the other end so now hopefully this
gives you a sense of what we're really
talking about when we talk about big
data it's not just sort of a you know
term that's thrown around it actually
refers to a very specific type or
quality of data so how did we whoops hey
just click something I shouldn't there
we go okay so how did we arrive at you
know the place where we're able to take
advantage of big data that you know how
do we get from the point that we would
have an individual gathering data in a
lab to you know working with kind of big
data set one of the drivers behind this
is that we have faster and cheaper
technology and it's getting even faster
and you know more cheap the graph that
you're looking at here on the screen
shows the cost of sequencing a single
human genome over time and you can see
that it's dropped really quickly
especially between like 2008 and the
present it's gotten very very cheap for
us to sequence a single human genome and
you know it's not on this chart but it's
also gotten a lot quicker so the first
human genome that was sequenced in the
human genome research project that took
about ten years cost somewhere in the
neighborhood of three billion dollars
today a single human genome can be
sequenced in about 24 hours and it cost
about $1,000 so in just you know about
10 to 15 years we've seen the cost of
things go way down
we have technology that allows us to
gather this data much more cheaply and
in addition to that storage is also
getting cheaper so not only can we
create or collect the data we're also
able to keep it and you know in some
cases keep it indefinitely
we're also sort of seeing a change in
the ways that data are gathered we are
surrounded in you know our everyday
lives in many cases by data-gathering
devices essentially you probably have a
data gathering device very close to you
my iPhone is sitting right next to me
and you know we think of it as just sort
of a you know a phone or a little mini
computer but the iPhone is collecting
data about us and about the world around
us all the time and there are a lot of
other devices like this as well some of
them are sort of you know consumer
devices things like your Fitbit that's
counting the number of steps that you
take that piece of jewelry that the
woman is wearing in the picture next to
the Fitbit is something sort of similar
it counts your steps and it also like is
able to detect your respiratory rate so
it knows if you're stressed out and that
kind of thing and then there's a lot of
sort of in the wild sensors that are
small cheap things like the RFID little
piece of plastic that you see on the
screen they're very cheap to make and to
collect data with and a lot of these
things are sort of collecting data for
you know a particular purpose but that
data can be reused for another purpose
entirely so the fit that data if I'm
wearing a Fitbit I'm you know probably
just thinking that I'm collecting that
to monitor my own health you know see if
I need to exercise more but there's
actual you know research potential for
some of that data that I be individual
user might not even think of so one
example of that is there is you may have
heard of 23andme
where you can you know get your genetic
sequence and a lot of people have
donated their genetic sequence data to
research and they have also tied in with
that their Fitbit data so these
researchers has
you know these two different data sets
to sort of work with and get information
about the people that have donated that
data so a lot of the things that we
wouldn't necessarily think of as
particularly being researched data can
be repurposed for that especially now
that we're gathering so much data around
us all the time there's also been an
increase in what's called born-digital
data so we have a lot of tools around us
that we can use to collect data in a
digital form as opposed to having to
convert data from an analog form to a
digital form so for example electronic
health records mean that we have a lot
of patient data that now exists in a
digital form and there are of course
privacy implications to what we can do
with that data
but we do have that data a lot more
easily accessible than back before the
age of electronic health records you
know in that case patient records would
have been on paper in a physician's
office in a hospital many different
places you would have to have digitized
all of that it would have been really
challenging but now you know all of that
data sort of exists in a digital form we
also have when we're looking at more
like sort of lab research as opposed to
clinical research the laboratory
notebook is sort of the gold standard
for recording information about an
experiment that you're conducting and
you know that typically has been in the
form of you know pen and paper an actual
physical notebook but a lot of
researchers are moving to electronic lab
notebook solutions where they're
entering their data you know into a
computer or sort of a middle ground
between the paper lab notebook and the
electronic lab notebook would be
something like a smart pen where you
write on special paper with you know
this special pen and you have a paper
and ink record of what you've written
but it also transmits everything to your
computer so you have a digital record of
what's been written as well so it's kind
of cool for people who still want the
paper lab notebook experience but
to have digitized records as well you
know we also have data in terms of
things like you know that I mentioned we
have all these sensors around us those
are collecting digital data and then
even things that we might not
necessarily think of as being scientific
data sources things like social media
and other you know data that exists on
the web have been used in many cases for
scientific research so Twitter
especially there are a lot of
researchers who have used that for you
know tweets as the the data for their
research one example would be when we're
looking at sort of natural disasters
people have tracked you know where
people are tweeting about the natural
disaster how that's affected them same
thing with illnesses so there's a lot of
data that you might not necessarily
think of as being research data that can
be used for some of those purposes so
another driver behind all of the data
science that we're sort of seeing going
on is that not only do we have a lot
more data and we have it collected more
quickly and all of that we have more of
that data actually available to people
it's in places where other people can
get to it so these are just a few
examples of some of the many thousands
of data repositories that exist some are
sort of you know broad in terms of the
scope of what they'll take Dryad for
example same share both are fairly
generic repositories that you can upload
pretty much any format any subject
matter of data for this and you know you
can whatever whatever you want to put it
there others are more specific to a
particular area of science for example
my favorite little logo is the mouse
genome repository that has a cute little
mouse on it it's a very very specific
type of data that they accept to that
repository some institutions have
institutional repositories that you know
if you're a researcher at that
institution you would deposit your data
internet repository so there are a lot
of different places
where
or we can get to data you know fairly
easily and that much of that data is
freely available to anyone who wants to
use it so this is a tremendous resource
for people who are interested in doing
research and you know getting a hold of
some data part of how those data
repositories get populated is that you
know sometimes people just sort of want
to share stuff for the good of science
but a lot of the ways that those
repositories end up getting populated is
because researchers are required to put
their data in a repository for one
reason or another journals in many cases
have started to implement data sharing
policies even some of the pretty big
names that you would probably heard of
BMJ several of the Nature Publishing
Group journals sloths and many others
and then a lot of funders are also
requiring that if you get funding from
them you're going to make the data
publicly available so currently the NSF
is was one of the first and is the one
most prominent that has like a data
sharing policy the NIH has a data
sharing policy for currently a subset of
people that get NIH funding so if you
get more than $500,000 per year on a
grant that data has to be shared and
then there are certain types of genomic
data both human and non-human that have
to be shared under the genomic data
sharing policy but I think that it's
fair to say that going forward
more and more funders will have these
types of policies that apply to all of
their funding across the board so you
know this is going to mean a couple of
things for researchers one that there's
going to be a lot more data available
for people to use so if I'm a researcher
I may not have to get grant funding to
collect data there may actually now that
data may already exist but I can you
know get a hold of and analyze for my
purposes and two researchers need to be
thinking about you know what are the
implications for them in terms of
sharing do they know what kind of
repository they're going to need to
share their data
do if they're going to share the data in
that repository do they need to have you
know certain metadata standards that
they have used with their data are there
certain things that people might need to
know you know to contextualize this data
so there's a lot of thought really that
has to go into data collection on the
front end if you're going to plan to be
sharing and so those are definitely like
I said things that researchers should
start to be thinking about now and that
librarians who work with researchers can
assist with and maybe encourage
researchers to start being more aware of
alright so we've talked about data we've
determined that there's a lot of it what
can we do with it so data science is
sort of a special way of approaching
data a sort of set of techniques that
are you know especially useful we're
talking about big data
so what are we referring to when we
refer to data science one of the things
that's important to understand about
data science is that it's not
necessarily a subject specific
discipline but it actually is more of a
method or a technique that involves a
lot of different expertise from a lot of
different areas so you may see people
who are data scientists who sort of have
expertise in all of these areas or you
might also see this take place more sort
of in the context of a team where you
have someone who has you know the math
expertise someone who has the the coding
expertise then another person who has
the subject matter expertise but
generally speaking we're talking about
data science we're either talking about
an individual or a team with these
different types of expertise so an
understanding of the sort of math and
statistical elements of what we're going
to talk about I'll explain a little bit
about some of the statistical methods
that are commonly used in data science
because of the fact that we're working
with very large datasets this isn't the
kind of thing that you can you know look
at each individual data point by hand
we're going to have to write some code
that will do that for us
so the advanced computing and the sort
of hacker mindset are important pieces
as well
visualization also important
in terms of you know having the
expertise to write the code to create
visualizations but also having an
understanding of you know human visual
perception and how to most effectively
convey information about a very large
data set with a visualization and then
finally again that domain expertise or
that subject matter expertise is also
really important we you know can find
patterns and data sometimes but it's
really important for a subject matter
expert to look at that and sort of
reality check whether that pattern is
really legitimate or whether it's just
sort of noise in our data so having that
subject matter matter expertise also
super important so another way of
looking at this is the sort of Venn
diagram where again we have the maths
and staffs knowledge we have the
happening or computational skills and we
have the subject matter expertise and
the area in which all three of those
overlap is data science so to sort of
compare and contrast this with the
traditional scientific method you're
probably familiar with the scientific
method as it's sort of displayed in a
chart like this this is something that
we learn you know very early on in
school so you know typically the
scientific method would start with we
develop some sort of a hypothesis about
the way that the world works
we gather some data about that
prediction that we've made and then we
you know analyze that data to find out
does this data support the hypothesis
that I had or has my hypothesis been
proven incorrect and once we've done
that we can develop some general
theories from that and apply those to
the real world and then you know the
whole thing sort of circular from that
we generate small hypotheses test them
and so on so this is how the scientific
process like I said typically works
things work a little bit differently in
data science partly actually let me go
back a little bit partly because this
formulate a hypothesis portion of the
plane stick method isn't necessarily
always the first step so a lot of times
when we have
a very large data set we know that you
know so for example I have the genomic
sequence of you know a million cancer
patients I know that there's probably
some significant you know genes in this
data set but I don't necessarily know in
advance what those genes are going to be
so it's difficult for me to generate a
hypothesis like I think the you know
whatever gene is implicated in the
development of cancer type acts because
there's just this huge data set that I
don't necessarily know in advance of
looking at it what's important it was
not so in data science a lot of times
researchers are sort of starting more
with the data set and finding the
patterns within it and it's a little bit
of a different process than what we
would think of as the traditional
scientific method so you know because
it's nice to sort of think about things
in terms of process there is we're not
you know totally throwing out method
with data science there is this pipeline
that is sort of a useful way of thinking
about how data science works so we start
first with what's called data ingestion
so we're getting data into our system
this may involve you know gathering it
from several different web sources a lot
of web sources have what are called
api's application programming interfaces
so we can essentially write a code that
will go out and find data that meets the
criteria that we're interested in
sometimes that data will be data that we
have ourselves collected sometimes that
data will be given to us by another
source but in any event we're we're
gathering data and putting it into our
system the second step in that process
is often referred to by many different
names you'll hear things like data
munging data wrangling data cleaning
data processing this is the portion of
our work in which we you know sort of
get the data into shape as you can
imagine a lot of the the data that we're
going to be pulling in to do this kind
of analysis you know I've mentioned lots
of different sources the web people you
know iPhone different sensors all these
things were sort of collected for an
original purpose but isn't necessarily
the same purposes what I a data
scientist might want to use it for and
so a lot of times that data will need
some sort of massaging to get it into
the format that I might need to do my
analysis often we're also sort of
mashing up several different data sets
so maybe I have one example of analysis
that a researcher I worked with did is
they were looking at gastrointestinal
disease and the weather so like is there
a correlation between weather patterns
and certain gastrointestinal illnesses
and so they had the weather data and
they have the illness data two
completely different data sources and
they had to sort of get that to work
together you know in a way that made
sense
so the phase of the data science
pipeline that's wrangling or munging or
whatever you want to call it is one of
the most important phases because that
saying that you may have heard from
computer science garbage in garbage out
very true and data science as well and
you're really going to have a very
difficult time doing any sort of
meaningful analysis on data if it's not
you know sort of organized in the right
way so it's an important step and it's
also typically the one where people
spend the most time so about 80% of the
work in most data science is doing this
data wrangling which is frustrating to
people because it's not like the
exciting part where you're making
discoveries but it is super foundational
and important to making sure your data
are you know correct so after you've
done that then you can move on to the
interesting part of the computation and
analysis we'll talk a little bit about
some of the different types of analyses
and algorithms that you might use in
data science but essentially this is the
portion of the data science pipeline
where you are identifying patterns in
data and sort of finding that meaning so
you know what are the relationships
between different variables and these
sorts of things once you sort of
determined that the next step is
modeling an application so the idea is
you know we're doing this analysis for
some purpose we want to discover
something or have some application that
we can you know put this into you so
this modeling and application phase of
the data science pipeline is where we
are you know sort of figuring out what
we can do with the knowledge that we've
found and then finally we have reporting
and visualization often data science
will be reported in the same way as
typical science in in terms of a
peer-reviewed journal article but a lot
of other data science is more you know
sometimes for popular consumption other
times it's more useful to demonstrate it
visually so there are a lot of different
ways that the sort of output of the data
science pipeline can be demonstrated to
audiences like with many charts that
demonstrate processes you can kind of
see that there are arrows going a lot of
different directions with this and so
you know I would give the caveat as with
most you know pipelines or processes
it's a little bit artificial to think
about this in terms of you know specific
steps that you know stop and start at a
particular point it's really a very
iterative process and involves a lot of
you know sort of back-and-forth you know
maybe you get the data you do some
wrangling try to do your analysis
realize oh David's not going to work in
this format so you go back and change it
and you know go forward again so a lot
of lot of back and forth and you know
very iterative in nature as many
scientific processes are so that is sort
of the you know broad view of what we're
doing when we talk about data science I
wanted to talk a little bit about some
more specifics within data science to
give you a feel for you know the types
of things that people can do with data
and you know the types of discoveries
that people might be able to make so one
of the very large areas and very popular
another sort of buzzword that you've
probably heard about is machine learning
so machine learning in data science
typically sort of involves
a couple things so we have some data
like I said typically a big data set
something that is large enough that it's
going to be difficult for us humans to
look at it and say oh yes I see a
pattern so we have our big data and then
we'll see that through some sort of
algorithm and that algorithm will help
us to find those patterns and from that
we'll be able to develop a model and
then we can use that model on similar
types of data to make predictions about
how that data will work so I'll give you
a couple of examples of how this works
and hopefully this will make sense so
there are two types that I'll there are
several types of machine learning but
too I want to talk about here and the
first one is what's called supervised
learning so in supervised learning the
reason it's called supervised is that we
have data points that are already
labeled with our outcome of interest so
for example here I have a bunch of
different images I think these are
x-rays of lung and someone a subject
matter expert has gone through and
labeled them as being either sick or
healthy I think the people that are sick
have tuberculosis so this is a
supervised learning task because our
data have been labeled with the endpoint
of sick or healthy and then the idea is
that we can feed this labeled data into
an algorithm and the algorithm will
essentially learn what are the important
parts of an image or in the you know
vocabulary of machine learning usually
called features so what are the features
that are important for distinguishing a
healthy lung from a sick long so this
you know could be a lot of different
things depending on the type of image of
the type of data that we're looking at
so for example if we you know are
looking at these images who might see
okay in the sick lung it looks like
there's a lot more white than in the
healthy lungs there's a lot more you
know negative space black maybe that's
what the important thing is you know
another example could be
if you're on Facebook you may have seen
that a lot of times now they have before
the image even loads it'll sort of like
know what it is like oh that's a picture
of a dog or that's a picture of a sunset
so it's sort of learned like what you
know what colors make a sunset or what
you know sort of shapes are often
associated with a dog so image learning
is you know one application for this you
know this could also be done with
numeric data or you know text data so
there's a lot of different things you
could put into the algorithm and
essentially it would you know figure out
what features are important and
predictive of whether the lung is sick
or healthy or whatever it might be and
then the whole idea of this is that if
we had similar images then we would be
able to put that in to the model that
we've developed and then the computer
would be able to tell us is that long
sick or healthy so it allows us to
classify similar types of data based on
what we've learned with the original
data
so with this one of the things that we
have to be careful about is overfitting
so in the image that you see here we've
got some blue dots and we've got some
red dots and there imagine that this is
on a Cartesian coordinate we've got an X
and a y-axis and the position of the dot
corresponds to an X and a y-value and if
we wanted to be able to come up with an
equation that would allow us to
distinguish between the red and the blue
we could come up with a very complex
equation that would be characterized by
this green line that you see here that
would perfectly a 100% accurately split
the blue dots from the red dots however
that would typically only work in the
case of this exact data we're always
going to have some outliers in our data
that don't you know necessarily easily
fit the pattern so anytime that we're
using a machine learning algorithm we
really don't want to get one that will
100% accurately predict our training
data because most likely that is over
fit to that training data and it will
perform poorly on other data so
basically we've taught it the
intricacies of this one data set which
may not be representative of the actual
reality of the world on the whole and so
what we would you know hope to end up
with is something that's more like this
black line where it you know does a
pretty good job of splitting between the
two groups it gets a few wrong but it's
mostly able to pick out sort of where
the red category starts and where the
blue category starts so you know when
we're doing again this sort of machine
learning sort of algorithm we don't
really want to see 100% accuracy on our
training data because in all likelihood
that is not going to perform very well
on real-world data okay so one of the
ways that we avoid falling into that
trap of overfitting
is that rather than training arm
on our entire set of labeled data we'll
split that data up and we'll use
typically you use about 80% of that
labeled data as your training data so
that's the data that you feed into the
algorithm that you know we the labeled
lungs that we're gonna put in and have
the algorithm figure out which features
are important to tell between healthy
and sick but we're gonna hold back about
20 percent of that labeled data and
we're going to use that to test our new
algorithm so we you know the the test
data has the labels because it came from
that labeled data pool we know whether
it's a sick lung or a healthy lung and
we want to see can we correctly predict
whether or can our algorithm correctly
predict whether the lung is super
healthy and that will give us a sense of
how well this algorithm would perform in
the real world so there are a lot of
different ways of splitting our data up
and doing this but typically most
supervised learning algorithms will will
try to split up the data like this where
we have some training data and some test
or validation data another machine
learning sort of application is kind of
the opposite of what we've looked at
supervised learning and that is called
unsupervised learning
so in unsupervised learning we have some
data but it's not necessarily labeled we
don't know you know sort of the endpoint
that we're looking at and a soup of an
unsupervised learning algorithm will
essentially find clusters of similar
data points so if I put in all my little
dots here the unsupervised learning
algorithm will be able to pull out you
know here are three different groups of
data points that are similar to each
other so the algorithm doesn't
necessarily it can necessarily tell us
like what each cluster means this is
where a subject matter expert would have
to come in and look like the computer
doesn't understand okay one is red one
is green one is blue I would have to
come in and
characterization but the computer can
find the you know data points that are
most similar to each other so one
application for this is so for example
if we had let's say we had a whole bunch
of articles from PubMed and we wanted to
find the articles that are similar to
each other we might put in you know just
the mesh terms that go with those
articles or we might put in the entire
you know text of those articles and an
algorithm like this would then you know
say we would tell it put this into ten
groups it would put you would create ten
groups of the articles that are the most
similar to each other and then we as
subject-matter experts would have to go
back and say okay I see a lot of mesh
terms in this group that are about you
know things like cancer and neoplasms
and you know chemotherapy so this is
probably a group about cancer treatment
and this other group Group B has a lot
of stuff about the heart and you know
EKGs or something so we the subject
matter experts humans would be the ones
to label those clusters after this sort
of a unsupervised learning algorithm
came in and identified the clusters so
that's a very very brief overview of a
very complicated topic and then a final
sort of application for data science
that I'll mention is text mining and
natural language processing so the two
previous types of machine learning that
we looked at can be used on natural
language but human spoken written
language is really difficult for
computers to parse because language is
complex there's a lot of relationships
in sentences there's a lot of you know
subtlety to how language is used so
natural language processing is its own
sort of field of study and research but
the idea behind a lot of this so sort of
doing this text mining and finding
information from natural language
involves labeling entity
within like a sentence or a corpus a
body of text and identifying
relationships among those entities so in
this example you know we have a fairly
simple couple of sentences but there's a
lot of different entities or things
going on in this sentence so you know a
natural language processing algorithm
might have you know be able to recognize
that okay William Shakespeare is a
person that's an author more
specifically he's a playwright and he
has the property of being a citizen of
the country England and that country has
the property of having English as its
spoken language so there's all these
sorts of relationships that are going on
here and being able to parse out those
relationships and those entities is
essentially how natural language
processing can work a computer can't
really take a sentence and just
interpret the sentence it really has to
be able to break apart the parts of that
sentence and that is sort of the area
where natural language processing is
working in certain Carnation today so
again just a few really quick
introductions to some of the techniques
that are used what are the tools that
are used to do these things there are
some data scientists that are using
proprietary tools so things that you may
have heard of like MATLAB and fast and
SPSS and Stata these are typically
expensive so researchers may not be able
to afford them for their lab the other
thing is that they because there are
proprietary data is in a closed format
not an open format that anyone can use
so this sort of limits the amount of
data sharing that you can do it means
that you know if I want to share my data
with someone else they have to have that
same program it also somewhat limits the
portability of your data just for
yourself so a lot of times I'm working
with we have a lot of postdocs at the
NIH and they want to learn a skill that
they're going to be able to take to the
next
where they work they're not going to
stay at the NIH forever they're gonna go
on and get another job somewhere else
and it may be that their lab at NIH has
spss but maybe the next lab that they go
to doesn't have spss and so I think it's
a little bit more practical to learn one
of the open-source sort of solutions
that you see on the right hand of your
screen so things like our Python Giulia
javascript a whole bunch of other things
that people use our programming
languages so the learning curve is a
little bit steep it is like learning a
language but the nice thing is that
they're free they're open source they
can take almost any kind of data and
read it and you know because of the fact
that they're free it's not a problem you
know when you go on to your next lab you
just get this download it for free no
big deal
so these are the types of things that
data scientists are more typically using
so R is my programming language of
choice I feel like it's very
approachable for beginners to learn very
commonly used in data science
applications Python also not super hard
for beginners I think it's a little more
complicated than our personally myself
also used in a lot of especially
bioinformatics types of applications and
then Julia is sort of a newer one and I
think it's not as widely used but it has
some potential you know interesting
things available so I mentioned that
learning to code does sort of take a
long time you are learning a language
but I do like to emphasize to people
that there's a lot of good reasons to
take the time to learn how to code so
one is that essentially when we learn
how to code and you're sort of opening
yourself up to being able to do a lot of
different things that you wouldn't be
able to do with point-and-click programs
so I mean a point-and-click program
essentially is a set of tasks that are
predefined if you want to you know work
with a spreadsheet you use Excel if you
want to
a word doc you're like I'm you know text
document you work with words but they
don't you know there's only so many
things that they can do when you code on
the other hand there's really a lot of
options that you have to customize and
do your own sort of novel analysis
create completely novel types of charts
so I kind of like to say that it's like
the difference between going to the
grocery store and getting a box of cake
mix and like knowing how to bake and
coming up with your own cake and you
know choosing the flavor that you want
the cake box or a cake mix box is easier
and it doesn't require a whole lot of
expertise but you're kind of limited you
get a vanilla cake or you know chocolate
cake
the baking your own cake harder you have
to know more but you can do whatever you
want and the same thing is kind of true
of coding so sort of a practical example
of that this kind of ugly
chart that you see on the screen here
was something that a researcher from NIH
had created with Excel and he knew that
there were big problems with this chart
so each of the color lines here is a
different participant or a patient and
the you know part of the problem was
that they had different number of data
points for each of the patients you know
some patients they had 10 points some
like for loss to follow up so they
didn't have all the points and there was
a lot of weird stuff going on with this
chart that made it not very pretty to
look at
so I was able to take the same data and
work with it in R and came up with some
charts that I feel like we're a lot
easier to read so I gave this research
or two different options one that puts
all of the participants on the same
chart and one that breaks it out by
participant so you can sort of see each
of the different individuals easily so
this is the code that was used to create
that as you can see it's somewhat
complex if you don't you're not familiar
with all of this but the nice thing
about it is that I can save this code
and I can you know share it with anyone
so
someone said oh how did you make those
cool charts I would be able to say here
is the code for it I can reuse this on
my own data so in this example this
person was going to be collecting a lot
of the same data for a lot of different
patients and basically all he had to do
is just make sure that everything was
sort of like arranged in the same order
and the same code could be used to
create this chart for any number of
patients that he would be collecting
data on it's also nice because if I
decide that like you know I want to go
back and forth like you know I decided I
don't really like everybody on the same
chart I want to split those to go out
into separate charts that's really just
one line of code to change and it's you
know fairly easy for me to sort of
manipulate the chart and get to exactly
what I want so you know I think this is
nice to be able to have your your work
documented for yourself but it's even
more important you know now that
reproducibility is a huge problem in a
lot of different fields of scientific
research I'm having this type of a
record of the work that you did sort of
protects you from you know any sorts of
you know questions about how exactly you
did your work it's all easily documented
for you so that has been sort of a very
quick introduction to a fairly complex
topic I hope you found that somewhat
interesting and are maybe inspired to
learn more about it and so thinking
ahead about you know what are the things
that we need to be looking at in the
future what are the skills that we might
need as librarians or that researchers
might need what are some of the things
that are going to be some of the pain
points going forward one thing that we
can be sure of is that data is only
going to continue to get bigger we are
seeing you know a huge increase in the
amount of data that's generated on a
daily basis and you know as I said it's
cheaper than ever to store it and to
generate it so we are definitely you
know not going to be getting any less
data any
soon so this is a huge problem to be
thinking about how are we going to you
know work with all of this data where
are we going to store it how much do we
need to save do we really need to save
all of it another thing that I think is
going to be increasingly important going
forward is figuring out how we can make
use of what's called unstructured data
so the structured data is that sort of
well organized neatly labeled data so a
spreadsheet would be an example of
structured data anything where you have
you know a list of variables and values
for those variables but that structured
data is really only the tip of the
iceberg of all of the data that we have
available in the world today much more
of the data that we have is unstructured
data so that would be things like you
know free text you know we talked about
natural language processing and that
would be things like you know tweets
like Facebook status updates you know
basically anything that is not sort of
pre processed to have labels and
structure so there's a lot that can be
you know potentially discovered using
that type of data but the techniques
that we need to effectively analyze it
are different from the techniques that
we employ on structured data and they're
a little bit more difficult to work with
and it requires you know sorts of new
developments to be able to work with
this more complicated data
another thing that's I think really
important to think about is training the
workforce you know we talked about how
there are these different sorts of sets
of skills that you need to be a data
scientist it's not enough just to have
the subject matter expertise you also
need the stats and the coding the the
researcher of today is a little bit
different than you know the historical
researcher and I have like this analogy
that the classical researcher is
t-shaped but they have a very deep
knowledge in a particular domain
specialty but the breadth of their
knowledge is not very wide if you know
anyone that has gotten a PhD I'm in a
ph.d program right now and it's like you
learn a lot
about one very very specific thing but
going forward researchers are going to
need to be more you know broad in their
knowledge and so the analogy here is
that the modern researcher needs to be
pie-shaped so they need to have a depth
of knowledge not just in a subject
matter but also in you know doing the
stats having the coding skills to do
some of that work so not just deep but
also wide knowledge so um to sort of
talk a little bit about how I work with
a lot of the stuff that we've discussed
I am the coordinator of the Data
Services program at my library the NIH
library often confused with NLM but we
are the library that serves researchers
on the campus of the NIH and so we have
a lot of researchers who are working
with a lot of different types of data
and the thing that I have found just
sort of anecdotally in working with
researchers but also in some of the
research that I've done and a lot of the
research that's you know been done in
general in the field but a lot of
researchers haven't had the kind of
training that they need to do all of
this kind of data science so we are at a
point where a lot of the currently
working researchers do need training on
tools and so that's a big part of what I
do there are a lot of researchers at NIH
and only one of me so I feel like a
really effective way to approach that
community is to do classes where I can
get many people at once and teach them
something most of the time that you know
what they learn in one of those classes
will give them sort of the background
that they need to be effective but a lot
of times people need some additional
help in figuring out okay now I know how
to use the R programming language but
how do I use it from my particular type
of analysis or to create a visualization
or whatever it might be so I also do a
lot of consultations on how to you know
use the things that I teach in
particular areas another thing that I
think is kind of interesting and I like
to do is assistance with locating
datasets for like sort of the the raw
data of doing data
as we've discussed there is a lot of
data available in the world today but
it's kind of tricky to find it so in the
same way that a you know librarian is
someone who sort of knows how to use
PubMed and might be able to find the
article that you know someone's looking
for more quickly because they know the
tricks like using mesh terms that sort
of thing same thing is kind of true with
locating datasets so you know
researchers don't have that sort of
they're not as conversant with what are
the repositories and how to search them
so that's something that I assist with
and then I think another really
important thing is building community
there are a lot of people I'm you know
I'm sure this is true in other
communities but especially at the NIH
that are really interested in learning
this stuff but they're very busy they
don't necessarily you know have time to
like take a whole semester long class
but there's a lot of people that are
like willing to teach them stuff so how
do we get those people together that
have you know the expertise and the and
the interest in learning and you know
people want to get together and like
share some of the cool stuff that
they've worked on and other people can
learn from that so a lot of what I try
to do is work on developing those sorts
of things we recently started a
mentoring program to connect people that
are interested in mentoring and people
that want to learn we have events like
Pi Day is coming up March 14th pi is
3.14 so we celebrate pi day on 314 and
we'll have talks and that sort of thing
so I think getting people together to
share the expertise that they have and
the problems that they have is a really
important way of sort of as furthering
data science as well so I will end there
and I think there's a little time for
questions if you have any questions that
we don't get to in this session feel
free to follow up with me by email I'm
also on Twitter and I blog at that
address that is in no way official to
the NIH I write a lot of stuff there
about data and
my ph.d program and also about my dog so
if you're interested in any of that
check it out but I'm happy to take any
questions that you have at this point
thank you Lisa this is Elizabeth again
we'll wait and see if anybody puts a
question in the chat box but I was
curious because your background was more
and you know social sciences etc what
you know what stimulated your interest
in moving into the you know the data
science area yes so I yeah my first
master's degree was in English and I
never thought that I would end up being
a data science librarian but you know I
was very interested in this when I was
in library school and you know I took a
class on data and I ended up a couple
years ago the National Library of
Medicine gave out these information as
grants for people to do work sort of
embedded in a research team and my
project that I got the grant for focus
on data and so I you know it's just
something that I found was very
interesting and it seems like a area
where I could people needed a lot of
help and I could provide a lot of
assistance and so that is sort of how I
got interested and you know my
background you know like you say is more
in social science but you know it's
there's a lot of free resources that you
can learn this stuff so if you have an
interest there's definitely you know you
don't have to put in a whole lot of you
know money or time necessarily to learn
that there's a ton of free resources but
you know I think it's well worth the
investment of time to learn this stuff
because you know I it has you know it's
made me really much more useful to my
users than if I didn't know it so
alright thank you for that what is your
PhD going to be in and so I'm working on
a PhD in information science at the
University of Maryland and my research
focus is on how researchers reuse data
okay right
we have a question somebody here in the
room hi my name is Jennifer um I I'm
just wondering as I shall I bore a data
science effort it's also part of the NIH
bd2k initiative yeah favorite question
so for those of you that are not
familiar NIH has this initiative called
bd2k which stands for big data to
knowledge and the efforts is the bd2k
initiative have really been sort of
outward facing they've done a lot of
stuff sort of on developing community
tools for data science so like one of
the things that they're funding is it's
called bio caddy it's essentially going
to be like the PubMed for data so rather
than having to go to all you know a
thousand different repositories you can
search across all of them with you know
one tool they're doing a lot in terms of
training and they're doing you know
stuff in terms of developing
computational methods and I work a lot
with the bd2k group so you know we're
we're not like officially connected with
them but I sit on several working groups
and those sorts of things so and you
know if any of you that are listening
that are you know interested in funding
bd2k is potentially you know something
to look at a lot of libraries have
gotten funding to work on things like
open educational resources like training
for librarians and data so if you have
an interest that can definitely be
something potential funding source great
we posted a link to that initiative in
the chat box for anybody who might be
interested so I don't see does anybody
else here remember if you have a
question quickly before we end we you
can put a question or a comment in the
chat box there's all participants and
while we're waiting to see if any
questions come in here in the last in
the closing minutes I just want to point
out that if anybody is going to the
preparedness summit in Atlanta April 25
through 28 are the disaster information
management Research Center will have a
booth there and be doing some
presentations and also during the same
time
at the world association of disaster and
emergency medicine congress in toronto
anybody's going to that will will be
there as well and there'll be people at
MLA for anybody who may be going to that
over Memorial Day weekend in Seattle so
we don't have I think we just have a
couple of hope I asked questions to the
host did you see that we have a question
there well don't we're checking that out
so I can see it here so my question is
how our metadata applied in big data is
it like with archives big picture
overview finding guy with links to other
datasets or individual experiment
metadata using something like dublin
core organized into cataloging software
so yeah so metadata is a really good
question and there's a lot of
differences in different fields so how
people do things in one discipline may
be very different from how they do it in
another and there's also a lot of
differences in the sort of granularity
which I think you were sort of getting
at with the big picture kind of thing so
there's a lot of discussion about like
what what exactly is a data set is a
particular data point a data set or is
this whole group of data a data set and
what level do we need metadata and how
can those different metadata schemas
interoperate with each other so there's
not one good answer to that it's more
sort of defined by the field in which
someone would be working and also
there's a lot of development in that
area to make things more interoperable
[Music]
okay thank you there's some more
questions can you see the questions Lisa
yes okay so a question about platform
for big data hadoop mapreduce MongoDB or
something else do you allow users to
deposit materials automatically or they
curated in some way so um at this point
and I don't know what the future plans
are for NLM there's not really like a
central repository for NIH data so
there's not really one answer so that
in terms of you know the actual
day-to-day work that people are doing I
know that there are people using Hadoop
there are people using MongoDB in a lot
of other solutions but at this point and
there's not like I said a single NIH or
posit ori where everything is a positive
I say there's another question about
roles for librarians or archivists and
when working with big data and I think
that there's a lot of potential rules
and if you look at I mean there's a lot
of librarians who are working in this
area around the country and you know a
lot of them are writing articles or book
chapters about what they're doing and a
lot of them have taken really different
approaches so I mean I really like
teaching are and I you know do that a
lot and I think that's really useful for
my user community I know other people
are focusing on you know things like
more of the data management planning
other people do stuff with like redcap
so there are a ton of opportunities and
I think that it's important to get out
and see what your community is
interested in so what can be most useful
to them where are some of the gaps in
services at your institution and you
know kind of see where you can be the
most useful so I know where it's at the
end of the time I can I say there's
still some questions but I don't know if
you guys want me just maybe follow up
with this individual on this or I'm
happy to stick around if you can go
ahead and answer the questions and
anybody who wants to stick around can
listen in okay so there's another
question about machine learning
algorithms and does NIH NLM offer their
algorithms anywhere for the public to
use so that's a really good question and
there has been sort of a movement in
government in general to make more of
the you know government software
open-source and I think we're in a
really good position to do that at the
NIH because you know other government
institutions may have you know if
they're working like with I don't know
like the CIA they probably can take
their software open-source but there's a
you know there is a lot of interest at
the NIH in sharing a lot of the software
and algorithms that are used a lot of
people are doing that on github so and
not just the NIH but github is a like a
code sharing site that's very widely
used and a lot of you know researchers
at the NIH and elsewhere will you know
mention in an article where the
algorithm can be found so
I think just in general there's a lot
more that needs to be done to help
publicize a lot of this kind of stuff a
lot of people make very cool tools that
don't you know maybe get the attention
that they need and so I hope that some
of the efforts that the BTK group has
been working on will make not just the
data but also the algorithms a little
more publicly available and then I said
there's another question about process
oriented simulations using big data such
as different steps that an antibody
might attach to a cell or bacteria hmm
I'm not really aware of anything like
that I know that I mean there's a lot
there's a ton of if you're interested in
any of the you know like publicly
available NIH data NCBI has a lot of
different data repositories that house
different kinds of data I don't know
that they have sort of the simulation
kind of stuff that you're referring to
but they definitely have data relevant
to that so I think that's all the
questions let's say once yeah that would
be the end of the questions I think
right now and I we just want to thank
you tremendously for giving this
presentation to our audience obviously
there was a lots of some good questions
there and stimulate a lot of thought
this is a whole new direction again for
librarians and you know the combination
of information science and librarianship
really you know it's really apparent
here how the two relate and a whole new
skill set to learn resources are out
there to learn it so so if there aren't
any other questions I mean we put the
slide on the screen about if anybody
wanted to get the mla seat credits we
have that up there our next webinar will
likely be in two months in June I think
the exact date is June 8th I think is
the next
session oh I'm sorry may I get may I'm
sorry May 11
okay so may 11th and again Lisa thank
you very much and if anybody like to get
in touch with her she did provide her
contact information and if for some
reason you can't find that you can
always contact us and we can connect you
okay all right well thank you everyone
will sign off now thank you okay bye